the three things that are keeping Cable
in business first thing all folks
listening watching TV okay they just
want to go home and watch Fox CNN MSNBC
that's kind of how they get their news
no problem okay and there's a timeline
to that you know I'm 44 years old I'm
not living forever okay so old folks are
not going to be around forever when
they're watching what they're watching
number two is sports so cable for the
longest Sam has always had Sports
football soccer Baseball sports teams
are now saying I'm gonna do it myself
and not only that streaming companies
are now offering money to who Sports
deals and saying hey bring the NFL to us
we're Amazon bring this to us so Cable's
like wait a minute wait a minute we
thought our only competition was DirecTV
and now DirecTV is running out of money
but you guys can't pick this up to
stream and why would anybody want to
watch streaming and Tom who one day said
I said dude I gotta watch this game Tom
how am I going to be able to watch this
game it says Pat go on Hulu you can
watch the baseball game on a phone